si dejamos que un altavoz haga una breve
ráfaga crearemos una onda de pulso
podemos encontrar la rapidez del sonido
observando la rapidez de esta región
comprimida a medida que viaja a través
del medio en aire no húmedo a 20 grados
celsius la rapidez del sonido es de
aproximadamente 343 metros por segundo
o 767 millas por hora también podemos
ver la rapidez del sonido de una onda
armónica simple que se repite la rapidez
de la onda nuevamente puede determinarse
por la rapidez de las regiones
comprimidas a medida que viajan a través
del medio tengan en cuenta que la
rapidez del sonido no significa la
rapidez de las moléculas de aire a
medida que se mueven hacia adelante y
hacia atrás las moléculas de aire se
mueven con la rapidez pero por la
rapidez del sonido nos referimos a la
rapidez de la perturbación a medida que
se mueve a través de las moléculas de
aire llamamos al sonido una onda
longitudinal porque la onda viaja
paralela a la línea trazada por las
oscilaciones del medio el otro tipo de
onda es la onda
bersal las ondas transversales ocurren
cuando la rapidez de la onda apunta
perpendicular a las oscilaciones del
medio las ondas en una cuerda o las
ondas en la superficie del agua son
ejemplos de ondas transversales si
miramos una gráfica del desplazamiento
del aire contra la posición del aire
podemos ver que a medida que la onda
viaja la forma de esta onda viaja hacia
la derecha entonces la rapidez de una
onda de sonido se puede encontrar al
determinar la rapidez de los picos o la
rapidez de los valles o la rapidez de
cualquier punto en la forma de la onda
para descubrir una fórmula para la
rapidez de una onda de sonido
veamos de cerca lo que está sucediendo
aquí veamos una de las moléculas de aire
se necesita un periodo de esta molécula
para avanzar y retroceder a través de un
ciclo completo durante este tiempo la
forma de onda ha avanzado una longitud
de onda completa esto se debe a que la
onda tiene que superponerse con su forma
inicial después de un periodo porque la
molécula tiene que volver a donde
comenzó después de un periodo ahora dado
que la rapidez
se define como la distancia por el
tiempo la rapidez de una onda de sonido
tiene que ser la longitud de onda de la
onda dividida entre el periodo de la
onda dado que la onda viaja hacia
adelante una longitud de onda por
periodo o dado que la frecuencia se
define como 1 entre el período podemos
reescribir esta fórmula como rapidez es
igual a la longitud de onda multiplicada
por la frecuencia esta fórmula es
precisa para todo tipo de ondas no solo
ondas sonoras porque una onda tiene que
moverse una longitud de onda por cada
periodo debemos tener cuidado pues al
mirar esta ecuación podemos pensar que
si ajustamos la configuración del
altavoz y aumentamos la frecuencia
también aumentaremos la rapidez de la
onda de sonido pero eso no es lo que
sucede si aumentamos la frecuencia la
longitud de onda disminuirá en ese mismo
factor y la rapidez de la onda de
sonidos seguirá siendo la misma de hecho
no hay nada que podamos hacerle al
altavoz para que aumente la rapidez del
sonido entonces cómo podemos cambiar la
rapidez del sonido
la única forma de cambiar la rapidez del
sonido es cambiar el medio o las
propiedades del medio en el que viaja la
onda de sonido
entonces para cambiar la rapidez del
sonido en el aire podemos cambiar cosas
como la temperatura del aire o la
humedad del aire o la densidad del aire
o podemos cambiar el aire por otro
material como agua o helio o un metal
todos estos cambios en el medio
afectarían la rapidez del sonido la
gente a menudo piensa que cambiar la
amplitud cambiará la rapidez de una onda
de sonido pero no lo hará si creamos un
pulso de sonido con una gran amplitud no
viajará más rápido que un pulso de
sonido con una pequeña amplitud en el
mismo medio solo será más fuerte en
otras palabras gritar no hará que nos
escuchen más rápido solo escucharán un
sonido más fuerte cuando la onda de
sonido llegue a su ubicación así que
recordemos la rapidez de una onda de
sonido está determinada completamente
por las propiedades del medio a través
del cual viaja